Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode
of the Grand Prixquel Podcast where we discuss all things feeder series.
On today's episode, we are going to be doing a recap of the Italian F4 and FREC weekends
at Monza.
Your hosts for today are myself, Robin, Nova, Peter, and Alex.
So do we want to start with Italian F4?
I mean, a lot happened.
I mean, going into the weekend, we were hoping that we could maybe return to the normal 3-race
format, because Monza's capacity, well, it was 49 cars, it had 49 entries.
4-race format pisses me off really bad.
Yeah, but I've since learned that Monza has
actually reduced their capacity to 36 cars from 49.
I think it's just for this.
Yeah, I mean, after that Imola start last year
it was to prevent that ‘cause.
I mean, even with less cars on track, they were all a bit crazy.
But also, I mean, it's not feeder series,
but like just a few weeks back, we saw GT World challenge and it was like a huge crash
into the first turn, specifically because we all know the first turn is the end of every
single racing driver ever.
So I think it really makes sense to, you know, try to give every single driver three races
if they qualify, instead of saying, you know, what's more likely that you get taken out,
especially if you have such a huge grid and crashes would be even more.
Yeah, like, the races were already chaotic
enough as is with like 30-something drivers, imagine all 49 cars, that would be horrific.
Yeah, so in qualifying, I mean, the US racing
dominance kind of continued with Edu Robinson on pole overall, and also with Noah Killion
on pole for race one.
Qualifying was nice in that Andy qualified P3 in his group, however, when it came to
the first race, he was meant to start P3, got a two place penalty for what was it, the
going over the maximum time allowed in qualifying, and like half the grid got penalties for it,
two places each.
So I remember Andy got one, Emily got one, I think Maccagnani got one, there were a lot
of drivers.
Penalties are gonna be a common theme this weekend.
Yeah, so Andy started P5 instead of P3, which
I'm a bit upset about.
I mean, Bondarev has finally had a decent qualifying.
Finally.
Yeah, he's been struggling a lot it seems,
I mean last weekend, the previous weekend, he qualified like P27 or something.
He's just too attached to his number.
Yeah, but race one, I mean, race one was,
I think the race I enjoyed the most this weekend from Italian F4, because there was
so much happening, and we actually had racing up the front.
Can people stop taking Consani out of races,
please?
I'm tired, I'm done!
That's just the French luck.
I'm done!
Like, genuinely, every single French driver
has so much bad luck, it's, how do you even do that?
It doesn't help that he drives for R-ace GP, there's already the bad luck there.
What did the French do to annoy the motor racing
gods?
Like, what did they do to deserve all of this?
Because, I mean, I think it's impossible to name a French driver with good luck.
I'm always making fun of Germany, because
I think it's a really, really interesting topic of how racing's here, but the thing
is, for some reason, the French are even worse at it, and the French have even more bad luck,
and in Germany you can point most of it down to the fact that we don't have any support
anymore and stuff, but the French have fucking French F4, which is like organized by this
whole organization, but it's still just, how do you do that?
How do you have so many also French drivers, generally, but not a single one of those has
any type of luck?
It's, the season has been miserable as an
Andy fan, it's horrible, I'm done, cancel Italian F4 2026, we don't need that anymore.
But yeah, so when Andy got taken out by Killion, somehow Bondarev also got involved, and they
both DNF'd.
I don't remember how Bondarev was involved, but I think he went off behind Andy to avoid
crashing into him or something like that.
Yeah, it basically happened right in front
of him, and there's nothing he could really do.
Unfortunate for both him and Consani, they were kind of, I mean, as normal we'd just
blame it on US racing, because we don't like them, do we?
Andy and Bondarev are both kind of interlinked,
they both suffer together, I don't know what is going on over there, but they're both suffering
together.
I was gonna say that, I was gonna say every
race, one of them DNF's, the other one DNF's either immediately or as a reaction or cause
of that.
No, it's not because of it, it's because
they're always DNF, because I feel like I'm looking at the stats side, and actually
Bondarev has not DNF'd so much this season, but I feel like every single time we talk
about him, it's like, oh, he had a bad time, he was taken out, he crashed.
Because it's at the end of the races, so technically
they're both classified, but they didn't finish the race.
And I feel like also we think it could be a
bit more on him, because I think the expectations for him were quite high this year, and
Yeah, everyone just said he would definitely
win, but at the moment, I wouldn't even be sure if he finishes in the top 10, because
he is on like P9 right now on the championship, or wait, that's the old-
P13 actually, yeah, he scored one point
this weekend, so- Oof
One point, I can't even laugh, Andy scored
nothing!
There's so much happening, I remember also in
race 1, okay, Payton also got killed by God knows who, it's probably one of the US
racing cars.
I don't know who car number 6 is, I need to
check that.
Wait, let me check, I can see.
6 is Oscar Repetto.
Yeah, so they got involved in an incident
together.
And also, I mean, the Thomas Bearman subplot
this race is crazy, he was just doing a bit of, like, I need to watch this race and
Only pay attention to him, because he was going off-roading a bit, you know, the thing at
the end where he broke his front wing somehow, he was going up and down the order, and somehow
he finished in the points, I don't even know anymore.
Savinkov was on the podium, and I don't like that, I'm not a fan of that.
And it was an US racing 1, 2, 3.
Cancel the championship.
Nuke it.
Nuke IF4.
It should have been Kenzo, but he got a penalty
for something.
His penalty, what was it for?
I think it was-
Couldn't figure out the Italian F4 Docs website.
I think Kenzo's penalty was for, um, leaving
the track and gaining an advantage, I think?
I mean, I don't care, let him do that.
Exactly, free him, he's already had enough
of a bad time.
He did nothing wrong.
Exactly.
Free my son.
But I think we should point out what we talked
about before.
Because last year, like, Prema and US Racing were pretty up there, but I feel like, especially
this weekend, US Racing was just so far ahead and like so incredibly strong, because obviously
part of it is also that they have like, I think they have like 7 cars.
They do have 7 cars.
Prema has 7 as well?
Prema has 7 as well, right?
Yeah, we also, we, I'm not part of the team,
Prema also has 7 cars.
The problem is that all of the US Racing drivers
have a bunch of experience, they're all 2nd or 3rd year drivers.
Meanwhile, Prema's lineup consists of 5 rookies, Bondarev and Cosma.
I feel like we should not call Ary Bansal and
Arjen Kraling like 2nd year drivers, because I know they did like technically F4 last
season, but GB4 hardly counts.
I mean, it's the same with Killion as well.
I mean Killion came from AU4.
Yeah, Killion came from Australia.
Okay, we should also not count him.
But I also think so, it's at least some experience
which is more than the Prema drivers have.
Yeah, exactly.
Well technically, Maccagnani isn't a rookie because he did F4 Southeast Asia last season.
I wanted to say Maccagnani, wasn't he the one who tested F2 cars?
Oh yeah, that's Maccagnani.
I'm not counting him as a rookie.
But like Aksoy did Formula Trophy, but Formula Trophy is like a fake series anyways.
I watched the race in real life,
you can't just say that's not real.
I think I watched Aksoy win in real life, which was cool, I was right next to the podium.
I think the US racing cars were just a step ahead this weekend in particular because
the fact that all of their cars would be in, like, the top 15 is just kind of insane.
There's reason why US racing is very, very clearly
leading the team's championship and it's like that's, I mean, we still have quite a few races
in front of us, but the moment it's the way it's going right now, I would not be,
I would be everything but surprised if they won the team's championship.
I predicted them as team's champions as a joke.
They were not meant to actually win it.
No, I'm not surprised.
I don't think I, I'm not sure I would have to listen back if I predicted it,
but I do remember that I really thought that they were for many years like the second
biggest team next to Prema and if we now look at, you know, the way that both teams have a driver
lineup, it really makes sense. Like yeah, even if you discount the
fact that most of Prema's lineup are rookies, they're just a bit weak, unfortunately.
Even the more experienced drivers aren't doing that well in Prema whereas in US,
they actually are and they have that consistency which Prema lacks.
Yeah, I think that's going to sound crazy,
but I feel like Sammalisto is kind of doing what we all expected Bondarev to do.
Oh no, he is.
And Cosma is doing what I expected Consani to do.
Well, I want to say one more thing about Race 1 and I'm going to have to find it,
which is what I thought was really interesting to me personally. If I'm going to f***ing find it,
oh my god, we have female drivers. That's really, really nice because I really like female drivers.
And in Race 1, we had this weekend with Maffi Racing, I think it was,
Rosanne den Drijver…I can't pronounce Dutch names. That's horrible.
And she scored P17 on debut in Italian F4 which I think,
if we're going to ignore the fact that Maffi racing for some reason only has one car which
gets on the podium and stuff, and one car which is, I don't know if it's the driver or the team,
but I still think that P17, even if aided by the fact that quite a few drivers like DNF'd and
crashed and exploded and whatever, I think it was really good showing for her. And I need to point
out that I saw her race in Nordic 4 some months ago and she's kind of the one that me and some
other people who are really into female drivers are kind of predicting we could see her show up
again in multiple races and stuff. I think she won't return in Italian F4 so fast because
the car is usually driven by Ginevra Panzeri who has a lot of funding for some reason,
but I think it's always worth looking out for these female drivers.
Before we move on to race 2, half the grid got penalties.
Three of the premas did. Aksoy, Zheng, and Maccagnani all got 10 seconds each.
Each of them for causing a collision. I don't know what they fed those drivers before the race.
That's the spirit of Monza.
They were doing something. Killion got 25 seconds for killing Andy, which is deserved.
Kenzo got 5 seconds for, like I said, I think it's for leaving the track and gaining an advantage.
I could go check the doc but I can't be bothered to go check the doc. Whatever.
A couple other drivers that aren't really super relevant unfortunately also got 5 seconds.
I don't know if it changed the point standings at all but whatever.
So race 2.
The horrors continued for Consani.
Italian F4 is a fake series. I don't want to talk about it.
In this race, I quite enjoyed Aksoy's racecraft because he didn’t have the best qualifying. He was
starting around in P12 or something around there. But I liked how he was able to make
his way through the field and be able to make the right moves. I think people kind of realise
Moving into turn one, you can't really make moves because you just gonna get forced off at the
chicane. It doesn't work. We instead, you know, began to see drivers instead making their
moves down towards Curva Grande. He made quite a few over there and I felt like he's been quite
smart and he made his way up to P3 which it was quite fun to watch.
I think he's pretty much–at the moment up to Vallelunga–He's won every single
rookie race win. He's the rookie race winner every single time up to Vallelunga. It hasn't
been updated for Monza yet which I think he will in this race probably.
Only race two he would have won in the rookie in Monza because...
Yeah, we're a great team so I was thinking that. But he still should have enough lead to go then.
I think he should definitely win this one because this far he's won six times in a row.
In every single race he participated in. So I think for the rookies he's definitely
doing a lot better than… especially you predicted, Peter.
He's really impressed me. He's easily been the best rookie. Not that the others have.
I mean we saw Bondarev's struggles continue as well.
He was fighting for the race lead and then suddenly he's off the track and then he rejoins.
And before we get into the conspiracy theory, Andy was running in the brink of
not qualifying for race four. He was running around P19, P18-ish. Bondarev goes off track,
comes back on track in P18 and suddenly Andy is nowhere to be seen.
The conspiracy theory here is that something happened between them.
I don't know, maybe Bondarev came straight into Andy's path or something, I don't know.
Props to Bondarev for being able to recover to P16 on track, promoted to P15 after penalties which
did mean he would qualify for the final because if he had not been able to get it back on track
and up that high, he would have been a DNQ for the final.
It would have been really funny if Bondarev DNQ'd with Andy.
But he qualified and Andy did not, so.
Race two was a lot calmer than race one. Race one was like,
I think maybe they realized, oh we need to be a bit more,
we can't be just crashing into each other, but that's in the spirit of F4 in a way that they
just love to. Walther got a drive-through penalty in the race for causing a collision. He goes
and serves the penalty, but he serves it incorrectly. How do you serve a drive-through
incorrectly? Maybe he sped in pitlane or something.
He served the drive-through incorrectly and so got a 6 place grid drop for the next race,
which I don't know whether that would have been race three or race four, but whatever.
Would have been the final, I feel like, but I don't-
I don't know if he participated in race one or not.
Because I remember in the final he had to come back, he was starting quite far back in the final,
so. Oh yeah, right, yeah.
And then race three, we saw our favorite win race three.
Again. He is dominating,
but it's like, we've talked about this, it's just not what anybody expects. I mean this
podium was, Sammalisto, Bearman and Cosma. I saw a stat on Twitter that said that if
Sammalisto wins the first race in Mugello, he ties Bearman, Antonelli and Slater for
most wins in a row in Italian F4. That's actually really f***ing bad.
Horrible. You're tying two F1 drivers and a driver who is for sure getting to F1.
I can't.
But I think it's also really good for anyone who wants to discredit drivers, because, you know,
I really respect all of them, but I'm just saying that if basically any guy who's in the right car
can do it, maybe we should think about what that means.
I think this really should show F1 Twitter that feeder series results aren't everything,
and that if you have a fast enough car, you can literally do anything.
Oh yeah, and that there's so much context to race results and everything.
Yeah, you can't just read the wiki and say you know everything.
If you're in an AKM car, you're not going to be doing that.
Nobody is. You could put Lewis Hamilton in an AKM car and he's probably not winning.
Put Max Verstappen in a... What the f*** is a P.A. racing car?
Okay, turns out I just saw something. We need to change stuff.
Ginevra Panzeri was not racing with Maffi. I swear there was
somewhere else where she was racing with them.
Just so we have that cleared up, because I don't want to get called out for my mistake.
We've been called a lot for mistakes before.
The Academy episode, I forgot to mention James Anagnostiadis
in the Merc Academy section, and I feel so bad for it to this day.
That's so bad, actually.
I feel so bad.
Actually, she actually replaced Igor Polak, who...
That sounds like a f***ing... What's the word? A f***ing slur.
But the good thing is, she already placed better than him, I think.
No, actually they're tied, but you know.
Okay, so if we are already back to talking about women,
Emily Cotty and Raffaela Ferreira crashed with a guy called Kuklane.
Kuklane? I don't know how you pronounce it.
Kuklane.
Oh, thank you.
Actually, what happened there?
I don't know.
Suddenly, Kuklane is turning and Emily and Rafaela are both...
I don't know what happened, but either way, it ended...
They didn't show us.
They did, but I just don't know how to describe it in a way that makes sense for the podcast.
But either way, the investigation ended with no further action.
So Emily deserves a gun.
I think she should be freed from the hell that is Italian F4.
Let her out of here, please.
She should nuke one car each race.
The thing is, from what I saw,
I think neither her nor Ferreira would have qualified for the final anyways.
Yeah, but it's better to go out with a P20 than to be taken out by another driver.
Yeah, obviously, but I think it just shows that
I would have expected more from R-ace as a whole because...
Do not expect anything from R-ace ever.
Okay, because apparently R-ace is just really, really f***ing bad.
And that's so weird, actually.
I don't know what goes on anymore.
So we're still in race three, right?
And we saw, if I saw correctly, there's no penalties or anything.
Emma Felbermayr actually scored a point, unless...
Oh, actually, she scores two points then, I think.
Yeah, we have it on the doc, if you would check that.
I'm looking at the doc, but there's like 20 different penalties also applying.
And I'm not 100% sure if all penalties have been applied.
If maybe penalties have been unapplied, who knows?
The top 15 that we have on the doc is the corrected top 15 after penalties.
Okay, okay, great.
So we have points by Emma Felbermayr, which is, again, great.
I think it's really sad because I expected Cotty to do better,
but also, you know, f***ing R-ace GP.
So she's, you know, the girl with most points, but also just like three points.
That's not that much of a difference.
But Westcott finally scored a point after she was close to points quite a lot of times,
but I know she finished like P16, P17, P18, like around that a bit.
A bit.
And it was really annoying because we all know that she should be able to do better,
but it's good that she finally scored a point.
That's very good.
I like that.
And den Drijver, the name is really s***y because if you don't know it,
it's spelled D-R-I-J-V-E-R, like driver, but there's a J in there.
Why is there a J in there?
She finished P23, which is, it's, you know, fine.
It's like not, oh my God, great.
But if you're in a smaller team, as like the second race she ever did in Italian F4 .
I'm glad enough she didn't crash.
Yeah, she had a pretty clean weekend.
In terms of penalties for race three,
Robinson ended up killing Savinkov at the end of the race.
So he got 10 seconds for that.
Bansal got five seconds for leaving the track and gaining an advantage.
Hattemer also got five seconds for the same thing.
So I think those two were, all three of those drivers were in the top five.
So it really changed around the podium and stuff.
That's why there’s less US Racing cars in the top five.
They all got penalized.
And that's why Bearman got a podium.
Bearman finished the race in P4, but with penalties, he moved up to P2.
Now Sammalisto Bearman Cosma is like the most random podium of all time.
I think I'm moving on to race four now.
We had quite a few drivers get grid penalties for,
but I mean that they're kind of irrelevant ones.
I didn’t even notice them during the race that it's kind of there.
One of these drivers, Orsini, he got six places for the final.
And then in the final, he got another 10 places for the next race,
which will be at Mugello.
I don't know what is going on over there.
I have not paid a single ounce of attention to him,
but he's just terrorizing everyone.
In Mugello, he'll get a 12 place point penalty then.
I mean, there's clearly a pattern here.
I don't know what he's doing, but he's doing something.
Yeah, race four and, surprise, surprise, US Racing 1-2-3.
At least Costoya was P4.
He finally had a good race.
I mean, they were 1-2-3-5-7-9.
And Kraling got killed by Aksoy, but he would have been P4-ish without that, so.
That is actually so f***ing bad.
This is horrible.
The R-ace hell continued with Bearman killing Craigie.
I actually don't know if Bearman killed him,
or if it was like a racing incident or something.
Or maybe Kenzo killed him.
Because there was no investigation.
There was nothing.
Neither of them got penalties.
Not even a proper replay of what happened.
But we didn’t see- we just see them kind of going off.
I love how you can just crash an R-ace car and the race stewards just say, you know, whatever.
They hate us.
It was bound to happen anyway.
Given the R-ace Luck, maybe his car would have exploded.
And Bearman ended up recovering to P15 while Kenzo DNF’d.
I mean, Bearman had the random weekend of all times.
He was just doing god knows what this weekend, but.
And then, I mean, Costoya kept on cutting the chicane, which was hilarious.
Genuinely, I was questioning.
Does he know how to take the chicane?
He literally got a black and white flag for it.
Just like every single time they passed by that one chicane, Costoya cut it.
He only stopped after the black and white flag, which...
Maybe he didn't know the track layout.
Maybe he thought that's just how you drive it.
Do you know that?
Have you asked him?
I mean, given the chaos of turn one.
I mean, it's just.
He was just trying to avoid crashing into someone in turn one.
Something happened to Bondarev, like we saw him pitting and his rear wing looked a bit
off and he was hard from the way.
We never got a replay.
I mean, I assume maybe somebody went to the back of him given it was the rear wing, but who knows?
It's one of...
I mean, there's so many mysteries from this weekend.
Race direction was kind of horrible this weekend.
I mean, TV direction, sorry, not.
I mean, it's been a common theme, like even in FREC, which we'll get onto,
the TV direction was questionable.
You know, they loved showing us replays at the wrong time.
Yeah, like in the first FREC weekend when they were showing us drivers going off into
the gravel, but then they wouldn't show us the fight for the lead.
We still don't know what happened to KNB in race three.
But I just feel like the problem with Italian F4 is also we have like 30 drivers and it's so
hard to decide between Bondarev, who's somewhere not in the front and you have,
you know, so much happening at once.
It's always so difficult.
I think, yeah, in F4, it’s more excusable but when we get onto FREC.
I mean, the misdirection in FREC is a bigger issue because they're missing things at the front.
We need to finish this race before we can go to FREC.
And what I want to say about this race too is that I thought it was quite interesting
that in the end, we had three female drivers all behind each other with Emma Felbermayr in P24.
Den Drijver, something like that, P25, and Payton Westcott in P26, which I thought was
especially interesting because we all kind of rate Felbermayr and Westcott and we know
where to place them.
But it's interesting to me that they are, you know, broken up with the driver who's name.
I can’t pronounce. I think Westcott went rallycross at some point during the race.
Something happened to one of the R-aces and I was like, which R-ace was that?
And then it ended up being Payton, but I don't actually remember what happened.
I just remember her going off the track and then rejoining.
My point is that even if she had some bad luck, definitely she did, it's really interesting
and it's a good sign for me that the driver whose name I can't pronounce is pretty much
up there with her and also Emma Felbermayr who, you know, she scored points this weekend.
I think she qualified in an alright place for the final because she finished the first two
races in like P17 and P15 or P14, I guess.
I don't know, but the thing is, I think she was not like dead last because I saw that
they were all kind of lucky because like Aksoy, you know, fell back and some others
fell behind them in the end.
But the fact that just timing-wise, the driver whose name I can't pronounce managed to stay
so close to a driver like Felbermayr who has scored points before who, you know,
she's doing something and I think that's a very good sign for her.
In terms of penalties, Aksoy gets 8 places for causing a collision with Kraling,
Cosma got 5 seconds for leaving the track and gaining an advantage, and like I mentioned
earlier, Orsini got 10 places for pushing drivers off track and causing collisions all in one race.
That sounds so terroristic.
And like he's not even a driver that anyone really pays attention to unfortunately,
so no one knows what happened.
But he was terrorizing the grid, apparently.
And I think this is an example of, you know, the stewards seeing that a driver has done
like the same kind of incident before and so making the penalty harsher than it would
normally be.
They did this to Andy in another weekend as well, but just if you're a repeat offender
of a certain kind of incident, they will just get more harsh when they're penalizing you.
But yeah, the championship is interesting, to say the least.
So Wikipedia is not updated at the moment, so we've had to go off of the graphic that
they show at the end of the race.
So if there's anything inaccurate here, that is not our fault.
The graphic and a bit of our own math to try to work it out.
Yeah, because the graphic didn't include Cosma's 5 second penalty,
so we've had to make a couple of adjustments for that.
So currently, Sammalisto leads the championship on 228 points.
Behind him is David Cosma on 181.
Aksoy has fell down to P3 in the championship on 166.
Was he leading the championship before this weekend?
Yes.
Wow.
But yeah, he didn't have, I mean, he just got a lot of penalties this week, basically.
Yeah, penalties and just overall not a great time.
Savinkov is P4 on 150, and Bansal is P5 on 143.
That's the top 5.
Drivers who are not in the top 5, but I think it's still important to mention them.
Maccagnani is P11 on 88 points.
Bondarev P13 on 73.
Craigie P14 on 68.
Costoya P20 on 48, and Consani is not even in the top 20.
That just sums up the season so far, I feel like.
Because the graphic only shows the top 20 drivers,
I could not tell you where Consani is in the championship, which is horrible.
It's never been so over.
There is no way we recover from this.
Two DNQs in a row, we are not recovering.
If we manage a top 15 in the championship by the end of the year, I will be cheering.
I think right now you're a bit dramatic, because I think top 15 should still be possible.
This R-ace, how do they do so well in the Middle East, and then combust in Italy?
The thing is.
Our car is not as bad as it was last year.
It's just our drivers are A, unlucky, and B, do not know how to keep it clean.
Probably a skill issue then?
If you look at how R-ace qualified in Monza last year, comparing it to this year,
last year our best qualifying in Monza was like a P17.
And I remember Powell qualified like P27.
We had Andy qualifying P3 this time.
So the car is better, at least in terms of qualifying pace, it is better.
It's just, we are so unlucky.
I'm done.
Let's move on.
Let's move on to FREC.
So first thing we'll talk about in FREC is that Thomas Strauven was only there for Spa and Zandvoort.
So he's been replaced by Kyuho Lee.
However, there is a FREC round, which clashes with both GB3 and Eurocup 3.
So we will definitely be getting another new driver in that CL Motorsport seat at some point.
No clue who they would put in the seat, but we're gonna get another driver that's not Strauven or Lee.
And obviously not Frey either because he's like ended things with the team.
And so I feel like the qualifying one, which I mean,
KNB on pole and Olivieri second, kind of what we expect.
But then, I mean, it is very much kind of business back to usual.
The two championship leaders qualified on the third row together,
Al Dhaheri and Wheldon.
So they were fifth and sixth.
I mean, given how Monza is, as long as you're decently in the top 10,
it's fairly easy to recover positions.
It's not as detrimental as maybe a circuit where you can't overtake.
Then you're more kind of screwed if you aren't in that top 10.
Yeah, so for race one, we had a big crash into turn one,
where Giaccardi just cut the corner and just went straight into two Rodins, an R-ace.
And who else was it?
I don't remember who else.
One of the Tridents, I think.
Yeah, was it Popov?
Yeah, it was Popov for race one.
Yeah, so Popov, Sano, Ninovic, Seewooruthun, and obviously Giaccardi.
And we're missing a driver, there was another driver.
I forgot who else was involved in the crash.
There was a lot happening in that first five minutes of race one.
What I have here with retired drivers on the wiki page is Popov, Ninovic,
and Sano, and Seewooruthun, and Macedo, and obviously Giaccardi.
Macedo was involved in that.
Oh yes, yes.
He's the driver we were missing.
So yeah, big crash on the opening lap.
I'm surprised they didn't red flag it, because we had a 10 minute safety car instead.
I mean, we just love safety car.
I think they didn't want to red flag it,
maybe because Italian F4 was scheduled right after,
so that would have been delaying everything.
I guess, but we got less racing because of it.
Yeah, I mean, it was still quite, I mean,
what was Seb Wheldon doing because he dropped to P10 on that first lap?
He wanted to test himself.
Probably just, I don't know,
I was going to say he tried to avoid the crash,
but the crash happened behind him, didn't it?
Yeah, it happened behind him.
I don't know what he was doing.
So the commentators kept getting confused between Wheldon and Abkhazava,
because they're both the two orange MPs,
because the third MP is Chi, who has the Aston Martin livery.
And they're running right next to each other.
Yeah, because there's an incident with Al Dhaheri,
which one of them, which we figured was Abkhazava,
because he was the one who was next to him on track at the time,pushed him wide.
Yeah, the two MPs were right behind each other,
and Al Dhaheri got into an incident with the one that was behind,
which the commentators kept calling Wheldon,
but it was actually Abkhazava.
Yeah, and this one was about the TV direction,
because the TV direction,
because they're basically showing KNB crossing the line,
where we wanted to see the battle for P3, cause.
For P3 between the three MPs was insane,
and I'm so sad we didn't get to see it properly.
Wheldon and Abkhazava crossed the line at the exact same time,
down to the thousandth.
They ended up giving it to Abkhazava,
I mean, maybe, I thought they'd given it to Wheldon,
because Wheldon qualified higher,
but actually, no, he got outqualified by Abkhazava,
that's why Abkhazava is ahead on paper.
And Chi was a tenth behind them,
so I'm really mad we didn't get to see that.
I mean, yeah, I really enjoyed the FREC races this weekend,
because even for the lead,
I mean, at one moment, Olivieri attempted to challenge him,
but then he got round back fairly quickly.
He was in the lead for like a corner,
and then KNB took it back from him.
Oh, you've had your fun now, my turn again.
It was a smooth switchback, I'm not gonna lie.
I did start getting very stressed though at certain bits,
but it's okay.
Yeah, I was too busy celebrating the fact that
Olivieri got into the lead,
that I didn't notice that KNB took it right back.
It was so bad for updating.
I was like, oh, he dropped down to P2,
oh, no, he's back up to P1.
But technically, Olivieri had a really solid weekend, I'd say.
If we ignore race two.
Race two is not real, it can't hurt me.
Before we get to race two,
I think we need to finish race one first.
Oh, yeah.
Get ready, get done with it.
Couple penalties post-race again,
Costa got disqualified,
I don't remember what he got disqualified for.
Some technical infringement.
Kostic got six seconds for using race mode too early,
and Stolcermanis got 10 seconds for using race mode too early.
Don't know why six seconds specifically.
It is quite a common penalty this weekend, actually.
I mean, it's interesting,
We’ve not really seen this penalty before, have we?
I don't think so.
But I do like these more specific penalties,
even if they look a bit silly, I think it's better if,
especially with a technical thing like that,
it's probably just like someone hit some button too early,
like it happens, you know,
I don't think it's worth giving a huge penalty
that will totally destroy the race if it wasn't done maliciously.
Yeah, I guess, but I don't know what exactly they used
to judge how much of a penalty they should give
and why Kostic got six seconds,
and Stolcermanis got 10, but whatever.
Probably how long they used it for, I’d imagine.
Maybe.
Hey, like, if you use it for one second,
you get this amount, if you use it for two seconds,
you get this amount.
Yeah, I guess, yeah, you're probably right.
That makes the most sense to me, at least.
Okay, perfect, can we now go to race two?
Yes.
God, what a race it was.
I'm saying that Olivieri had a pretty solid race,
or race weekend, we can say, second race was a**,
but like, I don't think it was his fault.
Yeah, he literally just got rammed into by Macedo,
just in the chaos of everything in turn one.
Just, Macedo went straight into the back of him
and got a penalty for it post-race,
but I'm still mad about that.
Yeah, but if that didn't happen,
it would probably have been a good points haul again,
which means he would have thought I'd argue his best weekend so far.
Argument, it is his best weekend so far,
and it's a good thing that the DNF was in the sprint race,
because obviously less points are awarded there.
I mean, yeah, but he still would have loved to,
you know, get a handful of points still.
Yeah, but I think he mentioned in his post-race interview
after his win in race three that it was a good thing
that the DNF happened in race two and not one of the other races.
What else happened?
Al Dhaheri went from, I don't know where he started,
but he won the race.
Everybody hated KNB this race,
because Sano pushed him well in lap one.
I really did think it was Olivieri, but it wasn't.
I mean, yeah, both Sano and Francot
got 10 second penalties for forcing him off the track.
They had it out for him this weekend.
They're just here for the Olivieri title charge, trust me.
Sano just wanted to help his teammate.
I mean,Wheldon.
He finished P2 on track,
then he got a 10 second, about two separate 5 second penalties.
I mean, yeah, I mean, I counted 10 drivers got penalties after the race.
10.
That set of investigations had the drivers in the stewards room until 11 p.m. that night.
The last investigation was Roussel,
who was the summons document,
said he needed to be at the stewards room at 11.15 p.m.
and they had qualifying the next day at 8.30, I think it was.
I'd be home, I don't give a f***.
Let them get their sleep.
The final results were only classified at 2 in the morning.
The stewards had a long weekend with whatever the hell these races were.
I mean, I don't think, I mean, even Al Dhaheri had this moment where
I'm not too sure what happened in the build up to it,
because again, the TV direction missed it,
but like he got swamped by everyone using race mode maybe and he fell back like four positions.
Again, not too sure what happened there,
be nice if the TV would show it, but.
Hell, after being forced off track twice, KNB ended in fifth.
Maybe they didn't force off track hard enough.
Seriously, he inherited like four positions from penalties?
Yeah, he inherited three because on track he finished in P8 and then it was P5.
Oh yeah, so penalties.
There's a lot of them.
Ninovic, 10 seconds for crashing Popov.
Wheldon, 10 seconds, five, like two five second penalties
for leaving the track and gaining an advantage and overtaking off track.
Sano, 10 seconds for forcing KNB off.
Francot, 10 seconds also for forcing KNB off.
Macedo, 10 seconds for crashing into Olivieri.
Seewooruthun, five seconds for leaving the track and gaining an advantage.
Costa, also five seconds for leaving the track and gaining an advantage.
Roussel, six seconds converted into a three-place for a job because he DNF'd
in the race for a race mode violation.
Munoz, 10 seconds converted to five places for the next race for forcing Maschio off track.
And Abkhazava, 10 seconds converted to five places for contact with Gowda.
Deep breath after that.
I mean, I've said it before, if everyone gets a penalty, no one gets a penalty.
So in the end, after being on reverse grid pole, Dupe ended up on the podium with Hanna and Al Dhaheri.
Yeah, I mean, Andre Dupe podium, who would have expected that?
It's the sprint race.
Okay, but like, it's genuinely his first points of the season, so...
Yeah.
I mean, he'll be happy, but like, who would have expected that?
I guess he started on reverse grid pole, so then that put him where he needed to be.
Enzo was there.
Enzo Deligny was there for the race to watch his best friend on reverse grid pole,
which was very cute.
I really enjoyed that.
I liked that they interviewed Enzo before the race.
Then you also shared the picture where Alex Powell is in the line for the autograph.
There was a lot of old racers at this weekend.
I saw a picture of Colnaghi.
Yeah, everyone was there.
Deligny, Colnaghi, Yamakoshi, Powell.
I mean, even Ollie Bearman was there as well.
Okay, but it's Monza.
I would also be there if I was a racing driver.
Yeah, there was a picture of Powell talking to KNB after race one,
and then there's a picture of him waiting in line in the autographs,
and then there's a picture of him getting autographs from the MP drivers.
Great, beautiful.
Like, literally, you could just see Wheldon signing something, and Chi is just laughing.
You'd think they have a special line for, like, I'd argue, uh, I don't know, VIPs.
You'd think that Powell could just, like, ask them for autographs.
No, I think that he would get, like, special.
He would be allowed to jump the line, I think.
Like, imagine you're in line, and suddenly you just see Alex Powell is the guy behind you,
and he's waiting to get his autograph.
I would feel bad, I would let him go past me.
He's trying to get stuff signed by, like, the Prema drivers who he's already friends with.
I think that's ridiculous, and I can't stop laughing about it.
But back to racing, because this is so off-topic.
Qualifying 2.
Olivier was on pole, first pole of the season.
We have never been so back.
I think what basically set KNB and Olivieri apart in qualifying was
whoever was last on track was in qualifying 1, KNB's group was last,
and in qualifying 2, Olivieri’s group was last.
Yeah, it really is just track evolution, I think.
First qualifying was quite fun, having the two qualifying sessions,
because then you both, one time you're first, one time you're last, and it's evens out.
Yeah, so Rashid qualified, what was it, P25 or something like that?
Yep.
Yeah, so not a good qualifying from him, I don't know what happened,
I did not watch qualifying, I was asleep.
He, for some reason, in that qualifying group, like, um, group,
whichever one Nakamura-Berta, and Al Dhaheri were in,
they only started going out in the last 5 minutes of qualifying.
Everyone else was, like, there was only one or two people going out in the first 5 minutes,
and then everyone else went out in the last 5 minutes, so I'm not sure what happened there.
Yeah, but that's Monza for you, and what I saw from it, and what we also heard in Italian F4,
like, it's always Monza, and the qualifying, and trying to gain any kind of advantage,
and trying to get slipstream, it's always so bad.
So I was, while I was in-, there was still some drama,
it was generally not the worst qualifying session we've ever seen in Monza.
So a couple of drivers out of position, mainly Al Dhaheri,
but Dupe got a penalty for impeding, according to the doc, I don't remember seeing that.
Yeah, he got a 3 place grid penalty for impeding.
So, race 3.
Oh, what happened?
Saeter murdered Daryanani on the start.
And I think we have a spectrum here of how fast drivers go during safety car restarts.
Olivieri goes immediately, Sammaalisto waits until the very last second, and that's just a spectrum.
I mean, it works really well for Olivieri.
On the spectrum of Olivieri to Sammalisto, where do you do your safety car restarts?
We could assign every single driver a place on that spectrum.
Olivieri got away with murder.
Oh my gosh!
We need to stop saying murder, that sounds so bad and we're going to get cancelled.
We're not, okay.
We’ve already said enough things to get cancelled, I feel.
Olivieri got away with pushing KNB off track.
Okay.
And causing him to DNF.
I don't know how he didn't get a penalty for it,
but I am very, very glad he did not get a penalty for it.
I mean, I think he should be a penalty because then Wheldon gets P1 and extends his championship lead,
but it's also good for Wheldon KNB does not finish the race because
that gave him the championship lead, so I am in too minds about it.
Olivieri winning the race puts him only 20 points behind Al Dhaheri and 36 points behind the championship
lead, by the way.
The championship charge is so on.
We are going to win this, trust me.
Which means that I should really go to Hockenheim.
You really should!
Yes, go!
Do it!
Go!
I should, I should.
This podcast situation is a little bit rough, by the way, because I'm a diehard Oliveri fan.
Nova is a diehard Nakamura-Berta fan, and Peter is a diehard Wheldon fan,
and Alex is just here because Monza.
He just loves Monza.
Yeah, so it's a bit of a rough situation in the Grand Prixquel podcast house.
I mean, Nova is depressed because KNB was just dead.
I mean, I think Rob is quite happy.
I mean, and I'm just overjoyed because Wheldon, I mean, apart from race two, which we ignore,
he had two really strong races otherwise, especially race three.
Yeah, we all ignore race two.
Race two is, it cannot hurt us.
But race three, I mean, Wheldon, he started around P7 or so, and then he made his way up,
he made his overtakes, and-
Last lap, those last few laps actually, there was so much going on, and again,
TV direction was horrible.
So Al Dhaheri just went into Abkhazava, we got a safety car for it,
and then we got a last lap shootout because, for some reason, we love last lap shootouts
as if nothing ever goes wrong.
But it's cool, especially around Monza.
Everything goes wrong during last lap shootouts.
I mean, Yuki Sano, oh my god, he was just-
What did they feed him during the safety car because-
That was crazy.
He went from P7 to P3 in that last lap.
He was a little bit aided by the fact that Gomez and Popov had a collision,
but even then, he just overtook everyone in front of him and ended up P3,
and it's his first podium in Europe.
And what a way to get your first podium.
And in Monza!
I mean, the final few laps were just chaos because the safety card was brought out
after Al Dhaheri and Abkhazava had a collision.
Nobody;s fault really, the  steward said no further action,
then as we mentioned on the race start, Popov and Gomez collided.
I'm surprised that Gomez managed to finish the race.
Let alone, I'm pretty sure he was like P4.
Yeah, he wasn't P4, and I also wanted to point out which one thing I'm really happy about
is the fact that Jules Roussel also finally scored his first points with a really good P6.
So that's truly good for him, and I'm very happy.
Our race was really good for everyone except KNB.
Oh, kill me.
I also- It's interesting how fast that investigation got shut down.
Yeah, exactly.
We got it during the race.
I was worried that we'd have to wait hours post-race for them to be like,
oh yeah, we're giving Olivieri a 10 second penalty after he celebrated his win at his home race.
But no, they just-
But they wouldn't do it because an Italian winning in Monza is not going to get penalized.
For once, I benefit from a driver not getting a fair penalty.
I'm still not over Eurocup 3.
I'm not over that.
But yeah, so again, surprised that Gomez still managed to finish the race in P4
after going airborne.
And finally, we need to talk about the penalties from this race because
every single race has penalties!
So, Rene Francot got 10 seconds before going off the track.
Abhkazava got 3 place grid drop because he jumped start.
Macedo, 8 seconds for race mode violation.
Lee, 15 seconds for race mode violation.
Giaccardi, 6 seconds for race mode violation.
How did so many drivers get a race mode violation penalty?
I don't know what they're doing with that button.
How long did Lee use it to get 15 second penalty?
He just used it the whole first lap with waste mode.
He can't use it on the first lap of the race or the first lap after the safety car restart.
I guess they were using it after the safety car restarts
because I assume they know they can't use it on the first lap.
I mean, this is like IndyCar push-the-pass.
Exactly.
But yeah, that race was insane and it has a good amount of championship implications.
So, I mean, the top 3 are kind of breaking away with Wheldon, KNB, Al Dhaheri.
I mean, the lead keeps on switching between them.
I mean, Al Dhaheriwas leading again to the weekend.
Then KNB took the lead after race 1.
And then Wheldon was temporarily back in the lead after race 2 before his penalties.
And then Wheldon took the lead back after race 3.
I mean, Al Dhaheri dropped back a bit because he had a bit of a weaker weekend,
but I mean, it still only…what? 16 points separating the top 3.
That is not a lot.
Olivieri is really closing the gap down.
I mean, he was at least 50 points back, if not more, a couple of weekends ago.
Now he's 20 behind Al Dhaheri and 36 behind Wheldon.
If he really locks in, I really do think he could join in in that title fight
because he's on 85 points at the moment.
I've really enjoyed watching Wheldon and I feel like we should sort out his sprint races.
Because in both sprint races, he's finished like 19th and 20th.
Spa 1 got cancelled, of course, but in the future races, he's been so good.
And he's always been able to, I mean, Spa was a bit of an off-weekend,
but I mean, we saw Zandvoort was amazing from him.
Double win.
I think it's really funny,
like the weekends that all of the championship contenders had or like
most people at the top of the championship had.
Because if you saw the Instagram post from FREC, it was like,
‘Who impressed you the most this weekend?’
And it was like, guy who finished P2 DNF P1, guy who finished on the podium twice and DNF.
Or like P20 or something like that.
Guy who finished P1, P5, and DNF.
All of them had one bad race each.
It was really funny.
There's only one driver who finished in the points in all three races.
Do you want to guess who it is?
I know it because I saw the list.
Yeah, Gomez.
Oh, but Gomez?
Hanna also.
Oh, Hanna had a hell of a weekend.
Oh yeah, I forgot about him.
Just completely fake news.
Thank you.
Fake news being spread on the Grand Prixquel podcast.
Hanna had actually a really good weekend because.
Get P3, P2, and P8.
Like that's really funny.
He's actually been struggling a bit before I feel like,
but he finally had a solid qualifying.
And I mean, I mean, Wheldon was stuck for so long behind him.
So what I think is most interesting about the standings right now is that we have
generally three teams fighting for the win.
And I'm glad because what I said at the beginning of the year is right.
MP is a really strong team and especially around tracks like Monza that they know very well.
I think they're very clearly a real threat and real team that can,
you know, compete for the title.
And there's reason why they are in P2 in the team's standings and only like 10 points behind R-ace.
I think it's really interesting how our ace just like,
because we had a really bad weekend with,
or like a couple of really bad weekends with Olivieri and Sano.
It was just Al Dhaheri that was scoring points.
But then we've locked in.
All our drivers are scoring points now.
We're all scoring-
Am I a part of it?
They're all scoring.
Yeah, I'm one of the drivers.
They're all scoring podiums now.
And we've really locked in P1 in the team's standings now.
And I really just hope they can keep up the pace, really.
I love you.
But like, we're not locked in.
We haven't won this yet because I think it's very telling that the beast,
the beast like rival to R-ace will definitely be MP with
Wheldon who's clearly ready to win the championship.
But also the fact that Abkhazava and Chi can also definitely score some good points.
What I think is really interesting is that I feel like for the first time in quite a few seasons,
we genuinely have a title fight where I'm genuinely, I'm unsure who's going to win this
because I know everyone said it would be Kean Nakamura-Berta, but I think
it's not even delusional to say that Sebastian Wheldon is definitely on his level.
And if things fall right, Rashid Al Dhaheri is more of what we've seen before where we have a driver
but win it but like no one kind of really expects it and it's more of an oh, you know, maybe.
But I think we generally have at least three drivers who are in contention here.
And I think it's compared to like seasons with Slater and Antonelli, I think
none of them are as clear off the rest of the grid as they were.
I think depending on how the next couple weekends go, we really could see two R-ace drivers in the
title fight and I think that would be really cool. Maybe that's just my bias. Maybe it is definitely
just my bias, but I think it would be really cool to see Oliveri and Al Dhaheri both compete for the
title alongside obviously the obvious picks of Wheldon and KNB. And I really do hope that Oliveri
can lock in. He seemed to fix up his starts because that first weekend he stalled on all
three starts, so he's really locked in on that now. And yeah, if he has another good weekend like he
did this time, who's to say we don't see him in the title fight as well? I mean, yeah, I technically
agree, but I think also if we're looking back at like the last few seasons or I'm looking back at
specifically last season, I think he's someone that kind of reminds me of Evan Giltaire. And
he knows that I absolutely love Giltaire, but he's had some real bad luck and couldn't quite
keep up with the front. But then again, I don't think that either KNB nor Wheldon are on the same
level as someone like Slater. So if both like the top drivers and I mean Giltaire and the same way-
forgot the name- oh my god…Olivieri! you know, closer together, it could happen, but
I'm on that level where I don't think we're going to see like so much surprising things,
even if I would love to see it. Hope you guys enjoyed the episode. And as always,
let us know your thoughts and comments. Next weekend, we're covering F2 and F3 on Red Bull
Ring. And I f**king love Red Bull Ring. And if I was not called monzabanking, I would be called Red Bull Ring
Lover because we saw so much great action there the last few years, especially in F2 and F3. And
I think it's one of those tracks that's really, really perfect for Feeder Series because it's
perfect. But I don't want to take up too much, which we're going to talk about next week.
Yeah, see you guys next week.